aux poudres et mathis merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur arte france alors ce
que l'on peut dire en tout cas c'est que
sur la forme c'est un peu différent de
la conférence de presse entre emmanuel
macron et vladimir poutine on a le
sentiment d'un dialogue plutôt francs
cet après midi oui je crois que les
choses bougent les choses bougent
lentement mais elle bouge effectivement
il ya un ton qui est un petit peu
différent par rapport au ton et à
l'atmosphère qui présidait la rencontre
entre vladimir poutine emmanuel macron
il y a quelque chose de nouveau dans la
mesure où il ya il ya eu deux éléments
importantes sont arrivés entre temps
d'une part y ait eu un geste de la
russie ce geste c'est de amorcé un
redressement en arrière des troupes qui
sont massées le jour la frontière
ukrainienne ça c'est un point important
le deuxième point important c'est que
l'allemagne qui est un vecteur important
de ces et en allemagne dont on a
considéré qu'elle n'était pas
suffisamment engagés dans ce processus
l'allemagne monstre qu'elle a une
volonté effectivement de trouver un
accord or on était dans un climat
extrêmement tendu puisque vous aviez
d'une part des pays occidentaux comme
les etats-unis ou la grande-bretagne qui
annonçait de manière très claire que
finalement l'envahissement de l'ukraine
était prévu programmée pour demain ou
après demain et puis cette volonté
effectivement de force et de
négociations
donc là il ya quelque chose d'un petit
peu nouveau mais on est encore loin d'un
accord j'en veux pour preuve ce que
vient de dire d'ailleurs vladimir
poutine dans son vin dans sa déclaration
en répondant à une question d'un
journaliste
nous voulons une réponse tout de suite
nous voulons une réponse immédiate
l'élargissement de l'otan à l'ukraine ça
n'est pas possible ça n'est pas
envisageable c'est là que réside un des
problèmes l'essentiel c'est que les
occidentaux l'assuré serons fermes il
n'est pas question de refuser l ukraine
le droit comme dans tout pays souverain
de choisir ses propres aux alliances
donc il va falloir trouver qu'elle est
l'astuce est ce que c'est l'astuce
consiste à dire eh bien finalement les
la récente le temps n'est pas à l'ordre
du jour oui mais dit vladimir poutine
passe alors le jour aujourd'hui et
pourquoi pas à l'ordre du jour demain
donc c'est cette garantie finalement qui
pose un véritable problème ni un
deuxième problème dans cette négociation
qui est important qui a l'air qui relève
finalement du respect des accords dits
de minsk c'est finalement que l'ukraine
accepte finalement de de répondre
d'accepter ses engagements et en
particulier dans sa promesse d'une
discussion vers l'autonomie d'une région
russophone comme le draw baston
cherchant du sujet je pense qu'il y a
des progrès qui sont possibles mais là
ce qu'on a évité je pense l'avenir va
nous lire mais on a peut-être évité
d'avoir une catastrophe qui s'annonce et
dans les jours à venir et deux sur ce
plan-là je pense peut-être qu'on a un
début de retour à sherpa calme alors il
ya de deux points très importants qui
était évidemment scruté à l'occasion de
cette rencontre entre le chancelier
allemand et le président russe d'abord
c'est est-ce que la la la la la la la
continuité des efforts diplomatiques
pour résoudre cette crise craignant
visiblement et au la chose l'a rappelé
il a dit que les efforts diplomatiques
pour éviter un conflit sont loin d'être
épuisées et puis sur la question
d'une éventuelle invasion russe
justement en ukraine sur une escalade du
conflit vladimir poutine a s'est montré
rassurant puisqu'il a dit la russie ne
veut pas ne veut bien sûr pas d'une
guerre
dit qu'il ne veut pas d'une guerre mais
il a quand même dit de manière très
claire que si il y à une attaque par
exemple de groupe a contrôlé ukrainien
qui viendraient attaqué des positions
russes il y aura une réponse immédiate
donc jusqu'où ne votons pas d'une guerre
d'un moment on joue avec des allumettes
quand on joue avec des allumettes on dit
ça nos enfants est vrai il ya un moment
où ça n'est pas possible il ya un moment
où effectivement aux risques sont des
dérapages et là on était arrivé à un
moment au risque et des dérapages donc
passé de revenir un an on va pouvoir
rediscuter sur des bases un peu plus
calmes et un peu plus confiantes o'neill
pas encore la confiance n'est pas en vue
mais la confiance pu revenir mais il ya
deux conditions pour ça la première
condition c'est peut-être que vladimir
poutine qui est quand même un leader qui
est parfois imprévisibles notamment vu
les occidentaux et bien réduire tout in
donné la pression qui se situait encore
à une période qui était inférieur de la
guerre froide nous ne sommes plus en
période de guerre froide nous ne sommes
plus en période où des blogs se
protègent en faisant une espèce de
barrières sanitaires autour de chaque
bloc pour se protéger de leur sécurité
alors que côté occidental on a une
vision un petit peu différent qui dit
donc il s'agit pas de créer une guerre
entre deux blocs il s'agit peut-être de
restaurer des apports des rapports de
confiance mais pour restaurer les
rapports de confiance il faut peut-être
qu'on accepte de discuter entre nous
c'est à dire entre russes et occidentaux
les conditions d'une véritable sécurité
continentale et c'est là la clé si
effectivement on peut apporter aux
ruches qu'une véritable discussion sur
les caractères de la sécurité entre
machines et autres et donc continentale
si cette discussion peut être possible
et si dans le même délai on sache
hureaux s'engage à ce que par exemple
des pays comme l'ukraine ou la bile
rouchy non n'entraîne pas de ne rentre
pas dans des organisations conchier
guerrière par la chine des organisations
comme le temps lui assure de pierre ces
garanties peut-être qu'on va avancer
mais tellement systématique
sur cette question de la sécurité
collective en europe au late show lady
la sécurité durable en europe n'est
possible qu'avec la russie il ya un
partenariat stratégique
russo allemand vladimir poutine a
longuement évoqué le gazoduc north
stream 2 mais il ya quand même un
trublion dans toute cette crise ce sont
les états unis quand même
kiki
évidemment
on des déclarations aussi qui parfois
agace beaucoup moscou oui parce que va
lui dire poutine ne comprend pas encore
que côté occidental l'europe qui n'est
pas une puissance politiquement unie a
besoin encore d'une certaine complicité
avec la force américaine et donc ça
c'est une réalité on n'est plus rien
mais ce que n'a peut-être pas mesurer où
la virgule la linière poutine dans cet
épisode c'est que l'europe dont l'unité
n'est pas forcément dans l'intérêt de la
dmr poutine et ben harper rester unie
unis dans dance caractère dans ce
conflit est donc cette unité elle la
pause avec une condition qui est une
condition simplement manifeste c'est
qu'aujourd'hui ne peut pas se passer des
états unis des pays comme dans le centre
de rang suite à l'éclatement urss
finalement ont eu besoin de se référer à
une nouvelle à une différente des
sensations de leur sécurité donc ça il
faut que la lumière quand il accepte que
pour les européens la distanciation la
dislocation entre l'europe et les états
unis n'est tout simplement pas possible
aujourd'hui donc il faut être la niche
reste il lèverait dans les deux sens
unis doit livrer pour la russie loi
devrait aussi pour les occidentaux on
rappelle aussi que le chancelier
allemand s'est engagé à
notamment avant de retrouver joe biden
dernièrement à envoyer des troupes aussi
en europe de l'est avec l'annoncé
justement d'un du début d'un retrait des
troupes russes à la frontière
ukrainienne est ce qu'on peut imaginer
une entame en fait de
2,2 au niveau de l'otan pour justement
faire en sorte que on apaise les
tensions
politico militaire aux frontières entre
la russie et l'ukraine avec cette
extension justement des troupes de
l'alliance
bon c'est possible c'est ce que vladimir
poutine souhaite c'est effectivement
qu'il y ait un engagement et qu'on y
voit un peu plus clair dans la stratégie
à long terme de l'otan qu'elle et quels
sont les buts que poursuit le temps est
ce que l'otan a pour but effectivement
de se rapprocher de par ses frontières
delà des frontières de la russie où est
ce que le temps avait des conceptions un
peu plus pacifique de la sécurité
collective c'est cette vraie question
qui est au coeur du sujet mais c'est
vrai que entre l'ambiance policier qui
peut exister aux etats-unis avec
notamment la pression des républicains
dans l'ambiance et dans des discussions
aux états unis concernant la réussite y
passe encore pour être l'ennemi
héréditaire
et puis l'europe qui elle beaucoup
comprend beaucoup mieux que sa sécurité
ne peut être assurée que en concertation
avec la russie je rappelle n'y a pas si
longtemps qu'un certain premier ministre
soviétique à l'époque qui était mikhaïl
gorbatchev par là une maison commune
c'est pas par hasard ça veut dire que
quels que soient ou pas qu'on en dise la
russie et l'europe de l'ouest sont d'une
certaine manière dans une forme de
maison commune donc il faut qu'ils
acceptent de se parler ensemble mais ne
demandons pas à l'europe de roches c'est
disons son allié principal qui est les
etats-unis et 2 ne demandons pas non
plus à la russie des choses actif et qui
sont difficiles bois excepté c'est une
extension indéfinie indéfinie de l'otan
dans ces deux conditions doivent être
remplies et pour ça il faut rediscuter
véritablement sur le fond le fond ce
sera la sécurité du continent mais avant
le fond il va falloir discuter
effectivement des mesures de confiance
pour retrouver cette confiance justement
le cadre de ces discussions
et d'un éventuel retour de la confiance
c'est un point de convergence il s'agit
des accords des knicks qui ont été
évoqués encore par rolls royce et
vladimir poutine c'était le cas aussi
lorsqu'elle manuel macro et est venu à
moscou la suite ce sera quoi
concrètement maintenant la suite ça
c'est très important de dire que la
chose après d'ailleurs emmanuel macron
et pu discuter avec jet ski en ukraine
pour essayer de voir le fond des choses
par rapport au pouvoir ukrainien c'est
sûr que si l'ukraine ne s'est pas un
effort minimal effectivement pour aller
dans le sens d'une résolution ces copies
je pense que si elles restent braqués et
6,1 sur cette audition qui est de ne pas
récupérer les accords de minsk dans sa
totalité de les respecter et donc
d'accepter d'une certaine manière une
certaine forme d'autonomie pour des
régions comme le dos basse et bien
effectivement on n'avancera pas et donc
c'est dans cette affaire vont parler du
forbin normandie qui se forme en
importance que sa forme bas qui regroupe
l'allemagne la france la russie et
l'ukraine c'est un format qui doit
permettre effectivement à tous et paix
mais je me dis bien tous ces pays de
faire un effort l'ukraine on voir un peu
plus l'avenir du diobass la france de
jouer un peu plus sur un équilibre
continental l'allemagne de trouver le
meilleur accord pour effectivement que
l'indépendance qu'elle peut connaître
actuellement vis-à-vis des dents les
perspectives d'acheminement du gaz russe
notamment par north m2 que tout ça ne
soit pas neuve est une solution tout ça
fait que ces acteurs là doit chacun
faire un petit bout du chemin avant d'en
arriver peut-être à une diminution un
peu plus important de la tension on
n'est pas encore au niveau où on
discutera d'une sécurité collective sur
le plan européen mais il jouera bien
jouer y arriver
alors au début de cette conférence de
presse vous avez noté que la dîmière
poutine a débuté cette conférence de
presse avec en rappelant justement les
les points importants dans le cadre du
partenariat énergétique entre la russie
et l'allemagne il a rappelé que
l'allemagne a reçu 57 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz donc dans le cadre
de ce projet nord stream 2 ça veut dire
quoi concrètement comment vous avez
perçu ce rappel est est ce que
finalement l'allemagne et plus largement
l'europe ont une marge de manoeuvre
aussi large que cela dans cadre de ses
négociations avec toi toujours
l'importation qu'on retrouve
régulièrement chez vladimir poutine défi
de piles et les européens c'est sûr
qu'en rappelant ses réalités à
l'allemagne c'est une manière de se
tenir par la barbichette en disant
attention tu sais ce que je sais ce que
je fais pour toi et donc à chaque fois
c'est une manière effectivement de dire
si l'europe était un peu plus d'idées
unis ça m'arrangerait mais le problème
c'est qu'elle n'est pas désuni et qu'on
ne va pas dans une séance de désunion et
donc là il va falloir en
responsable en chef d'état responsable
trouver des accords qui sont d accord
qui partent de la réalité et qui ne
partent pas de rêve le rêve de la guerre
froide c'est terminé le rêve d'une une
opposition franche russie
occident ce sont des choses qui doivent
évoluer bon et je pense que là dessus il
ya encore des progrès à faire et sur les
sanctions aussi un le spectre des
sanctions qu'agitent l'union européenne
aux siens
c'est clair que notre et 2 faisait
partie des champions c'est à dire le
fait ce si jamais il y avait une
intrusion militaire de la russie en
ukraine
il est évident que c'était arrêt
immédiat de la mise en route du du
gazoduc nord stream 2 c'était ça mais
c'est aussi beaucoup d'autres
conséquences sur le plan des sanctions
et vladimir poutine bien
sanctions contraire parce que certains
de ses ministres ont pu dire le poids
des sanctions pu être absolument
redoutable en sachant déjà que la russie
suivie déjà des sanctions occidentales
qui sont très dures depuis l'annexion de
la crimée donc c'est des choses qu'il ya
un véritable rapport de force et dans
toute négociation il ya un pas en ce
sens et là il ya un rapport de force
évident la russie a déjà mené elle peut
pas aller trop loin elle ne peut pas
aller trop loin à aller trop loin pour
la russie ça se fait d'exiger
effectivement qu'il n'y ait aucun encore
dire qu'on n'accepte pas le droit des
pays finalement à gérer leur propre
souveraineté
pour conclure finalement 7 selon ballet
diplomatique qui va continuer on le sait
dans les prochaines semaines on en est
probablement qu'au début pour tenter de
résoudre cette crise ukrainienne on se
dirige réellement vers une désescalade
on pensait
ça il faut bien sûr on n'est pas devin
encore une fois je prends que c'est
conditionné à deux réalités d'une part
vladimir poutine donne la pression
parfois déchirants taux de ne pas être
totalement prévisibles et chez sur le
fait de ne pas pouvoir lire
effectivement dans ses pensées n'a pas
facilité les choses donc on va voir si
vladimir poutine évolué est ce que
véritablement il veut éviter tout
dérapage des conséquences incontrôlables
et dont on va le voir probablement dans
les jours qui viennent il je pense que
c'est pas al azhar si les états unis de
manière peut-être très artificielle ont
déclarés ou annoncé une invasion de
l'ukraine dans les jours qui viennent
c'était moche y avait moyen peut-être
artificielle d'essayer de faire monter
la pression tout simplement merci à
beaucoup avoue françois poulet mathis
spécialiste en l'institution européenne
merci pour cette selon décryptage donc
de 7 heures rencontre entre vladimir
poutine et olaf scholz